for 100 years the iconic numwa tea
parlor in new york's chinatown
has been serving hot dim sum to locals
and customers from around the world
so to celebrate its century-long journey
owner wilson tang
that's his name is out today with a new
cookbook of classic recipes and stories
of a vibrant community of chinese
americans
and the immigrants who came before them
vladimir dutie
took a trip to chinatown for this i
think it's a mouth-watering assignment i
want to lick the screen
i mean look at it happening all behind
you there it is
amazing good morning everybody for those
of you who haven't had dim sum
they are delicious small dishes meant to
share in the company of friends
you'll see that the numwa story is not
just about its food
it's about the people behind it carrying
on a 100 year legacy
these are some of the top favorites in
our restaurant our first one is the
shrimp and snow pea leaf thumping
to truly appreciate numois food
you have to appreciate noise rich
history the food that we serve is
actually very traditional it's stuff
that i've had as a kid
my parents have had as a kid since 1920
numwa tea parlor in new york's chinatown
has become an
institution owner wilson tang
hospitality is in my dna
it is what my dad and my uncles have
done
when they first came to america as
immigrants it's the quintessential story
of the american dream
tang's uncle uncle wally worked his way
up from dishwasher
to cook to waiter to eventually owning
numoir
and ran it for almost 50 years meanwhile
tang pursued a high-flying career in
finance you exemplify
in many ways what all of us who are
first-generation americans
sort of exemplify to our families right
i did follow that path of
you know going to school getting good
grades and you know having my stint
in finance but i think at the end of the
day
this was my calling if i didn't do it
who would do it
over the years noir much like new york's
chinatown has endured enormous
challenges
from 9 11 to a global pandemic
but through it all chinatown has
survived and continued to thrive
i think restaurants in chinatown had
always
been the underdog we have a lot of grit
and a lot of heart
and what better way to celebrate and
showcase that spirit than to write a
cookbook
marking the restaurant's 100 year
journey i wanted something that really
talks about the neighborhood
and the mom and pop businesses that are
still around
from the local tea guru to the fish
whisperer
to the grocery store goddess the book is
an ode to a community that is close-knit
and resilient hey mr lee as we found out
quickly
while walking the streets of chinatown
your semi retired
yeah i try to retire but you know i
gotta survive you know
next stop fong on local tofu shop where
we found chef paul ang making a fresh
batch of grass jelly
aang revived his family business of over
80 years
with new twists to traditional recipes
we have a ginger
rice cake we like ginger we like the
brown rice cake let's put it together
eggplant and shrimp on this one this is
you know
very classic back at numwa some more
tang
family classics for me to chow down this
is also a fan favorite
and last but not least is our rice rolls
this is basically
rice that's been broken down into a
liquid and then re-steamed
uh on a tray and what is dim sum without
some hot tea
black tea with chrysanthemum flowers in
it cheers you
here's to you
the food at no moi is so good i went off
my keto diet to try some of those dishes
brought the rest home to mary and my
wife as for the cookbook wilson tang
told me he hopes his kids will read it
over and over again and be inspired to
do something for the community
just like he did one thing about this um
he wants
numwa to be considered like katz's like
peter lugers
like barney greengrass it is uniquely
american
it's chinese-american but uniquely yes
very much american hard for any
restaurant to last even
a year let alone a century i know but
i've lived in the city for over 15 years
never been to china you got to go
i want to go thank you
we'll be right back stay with us that
was good